exercise is one of the best ways to
improve brain function over time there's
been so much interest in should we do
crossword puzzles why is it that some
people maintain cognitive function
what's very clear to me based on all
that literature is that it's not one
specific thing crossword puzzles or
social engagement or exercise it's all
of those things but let's not forget the
superagers the people who are constantly
trying things that are difficult those
people are offsetting as far as we know
all of the major shrinkage of these
brain structures that normally would
shrink as people age so we have a lot of
control but it does requ effort there's
never going to be a pillar injection
there's no way that you're ever going to
recapitulate learning and effort it's so
clear I mean I don't know how many more
papers in preclinical models one needs
to see before they finally just bite the
bullet into go lifts lift weights and
run and do cardiovascular training it
can't be one or the other